[Música]
mi mamá
cuando era joven
perdió un embarazo
y eso significó que para poder salvarle
la vida ya no pudo tener más hijos
creo que en ese momento mi papá hubiera
dado la vuelta al mundo para poner en
sus brazos
alguien a quien poder llamar hijo
y así fue como una mañana de marzo
en el 69 en la ciudad de la plata
calurosa y húmeda como siempre este ha
aparecido
la verdad que siempre supe que era
adoptado
siempre agradece todo lo que me dieron
me llevaron a recorrer el país entero
porque mi papá decía que yo en algún
momento iba a recorrer el mundo pero que
antes tenía que conocer mi país para
poder valorar y para poder comparar
y aún así con todo el amor
algo adentro mío
estaba generando una pregunta
y la pregunta era
de dónde vengo
una tarde pararon en la puerta de una
clínica privada y me dijeron vez de ahí
venís
claro pero no era la pregunta que yo
quería hacer
así que tuve que aprender a preguntar
quizás por eso es que soy periodista en
algún momento la pregunta surgió porque
yo necesitaba saber
porque mi piel era de un color distinto
al de mis papás porque mi pelo era
diferente porque dibujaba con mi mano
izquierda
entonces un día pregunté por mi mamá
biológica
creo que mis papás estaban aterrados
y entonces hicieron lo mejor que
pudieron y es
permitirme darme la libertad para que
buscara
ahí aprendí algo que aún hoy conservo
como periodista tener la libertad para
preguntar no quiere decir que uno
obtenga ni una sola respuesta
pasó mucho tiempo hasta que logré hacer
la pregunta adecuada y me llevará a la
primera pista que me acercaba
a conocer a mi mamá biológica
y esa primera pregunta llevó a la
primera respuesta que fue que la
enfermera que tenía todos los archivos
de los padres biológicos con los padres
adoptantes con los chicos habían muerto
en un incendio durante la dictadura
militar
así que
mi pregunta termino con mi camino de
búsqueda
lo cual no está mal
porque cuando uno no tiene más
respuestas lo que empieza es el mundo de
los mitos
los mitos es darle una respuesta
improbable quizás o mágica a algo que
uno no puede responder y esto me da un
montón de posibilidades por ejemplo si
yo llegaba a la meta
quizás bajar a zeus y me permitiera
ingresar al olimpo nadie decía de que yo
no podía ser un hijo de él
me miraba cada tanto el dedo pensando
que podía encenderse y entonces podría
ser un extraterrestre kriptonita no
encontré
aunque secretamente yo estaba esperando
que viniera un hombre con barba y una
espada láser
o al menos un señor de vestido de oscuro
diciéndome
soy tu padre
pero no pasó así que lo que suele
suceder cuando uno no encuentra
respuestas y cuando uno no se puede dar
respuestas es a veces dejar que la vida
pase y
decidí generar mis propios mitos y como
yo no creo en las palabras imposibles
para mí la palabra imposible es un mito
entonces lo que hice fue llegar a esos
lugares que para muchos de ustedes
pueden parecer imposibles y así fue como
empecé a trabajar para marvel para dc
para disney y para warner haciendo un
montón de cosas desde la ciudad de la
plata
y entonces la vida se encarga en algún
momento de recordarnos que nuestra
búsqueda no terminó
entonces me pasó algo que no lo voy a
olvidar jamás y fue verme por primera
vez en los ojos de otra persona
cuando nació mi hijo
y yo sabía que no le podía dar un árbol
genealógico biológico
pero si le podía dar algo si le podía
dar algo que yo había aprendido con esos
viajes alrededor del país y que tenía
que ver con mis raíces
yo le podía dar a mi hijo mis raíces
pero no cualquier raíz yo quería darle
la raíz de los mitos porque yo había
recorrido el mundo y había escuchado
muchas veces acerca de hadas duendes y
seres fantásticos que viven en distintos
lugares de la tierra pero hasta parecía
que no vieron que parece que acá en
realidad todo empezó con la llegada de
los españoles
todo parece eso pero
decidí en algún momento que iba a hacer
esa búsqueda y entonces con un contrato
con una editorial me embarque en una
búsqueda de nuestros mitos
lo bueno es que no estaban incendiados
había algo que susurraba que había manos
apretadas diciendo que no querían hablar
que no querían contar otra vez su
historia para que fuera transversal
así que tuve que aprender a preguntar de
nuevo tuve que aprender a preguntar
este sombrero es parecido a otro
sombrero porque si bien no es mi papá
pero indiana jones siempre fue para mí
la persona indicada para marcarme cuál
era el camino de aquel que busca
y pasó algo increíble en tilcara
haciendo preguntas dos mujeres cosas
detrás mío
seguramente me señalaban y decían es ese
ese es el cazador de duendes
y entonces fue cuando dije estoy en el
lugar correcto estoy haciendo lo que
necesito hacer en la vida es acá y les
voy a contar algo que no tenía pensado
contarles pero que tiene que ver con el
tema de los mitos y tiene que ver como
los mitos están vivos
todo el tiempo van cambiando y van
mutando y así fue como en tilcara
escuché a un músico que se llama ricardo
vilca ricardo vilca toca una música
hermosa y para agradecerle como soy
ilustrador además le hice un dibujo de
él con orejas de duende no tocando así
con forma de duende y él lo empezó a
utilizar en este en sus recitales en sus
esté en sus conciertos y ricardo
falleció
y alguien
decidió que ese duende estuviera tallado
en su tumba
y desde ese momento en tilcara se dice
que a la noche en algunos momentos se ve
al duende vilca con su música
recorriendo los valles miren qué
increíble alguien que buscaba mitos
termina generando uno
pero en realidad ese susurro todavía
estaba esas historias que yo quería
escuchar estaban ahí porque se lo debía
a mis hijos que iban a empezar a
aparecer después este pero yo quería
contarles esas historias de antes
de antes de la llegada de los españoles
y entonces pregunté lo que todos se nos
ocurriría preguntar bueno en este país
hay sirenas
y la respuesta fue no
pero sin embargo cuando yo pregunté por
las mujeres con cola de pez empezaron a
aparecer la comida busquen las con él
aunque en el sur la más humana en el
norte la avanzará en el río paraná pero
no sólo eso no solo hay sirenas también
halladas porque los espíritus femeninos
que cuidan las plantas en todo el mundo
se los considera como hadas y esa a
quien adoro porque la caballería es la
que cuida la hierba mate y es mi bebida
este ella es un hada originalmente y no
solamente tenemos hadas
también tenemos duendes y un montón
duendes tenemos el acá en el sur el
chuvi ñola en chimal en el cuca blanca
pero además en otras partes del país
tenemos al bombero al guaira tumba al
cual ya está ahí al sombrerudo
es increíble toda la cantidad de seres
que hay en nuestro país de antes incluso
dragones
él huayrapuca es el viento colorado de
salta pero que sin embargo sus
características son muy parecidas a los
dragones orientales hoy ya sabemos de
que no fueron los primeros los españoles
en llegar a nuestras tierras y que los
orientales también estuvieron acá antes
aunque no vinieron quizás a conquistar
pero también tenemos otros seres y
aunque les parezca mentira acá también
tenemos unicornios con forma de ciervo y
el pudú pudú se llama ese ciervo y en
algunos casos se convierte en este
camahueto o el kauak agua que es un
troll pero con la particularidad
increíble de que es tan liviano que va
por arriba de los árboles o seres tan
fantásticos y únicos como el fútbol que
es el pez de plata y que levanta las
polvaredas para que los antiguos
habitantes pudieran escapar del asedio
de los españoles
encontré un montón de historias antes
y entonces
me di cuenta en algún momento
de que mis papás sin proponérselo me
habían colonizado
porque yo no sé quién era antes pero
seguramente hay un antes y está muy
adentro mío y quizás aparezca en el
color de mi piel en mi pelo en mi mano
izquierda
pero también me di cuenta de otra cosa
que en nuestro país los mitos también
existen y como todo el mundo
duendes y dragones nos hacen como un
enorme
globo pequeño donde estamos todos unidos
pero también tenemos que acordarnos de
que tenemos una forma nosotros también
única de ver a estos seres esa forma
única que todavía susurran los ancianos
en cada región del país y es importante
que no nos olvidemos y que escuchemos
esas historias porque todavía están ahí
yo aprendí algo en todo este camino
el español es un idioma maravilloso y
vieron que tiene un montón de
diferencias sin embargo hay un verbo que
es yo creo
qué sirve para dos verbos en un momento
yo creo
de creer
yo creo de crear
y yo creo que en este viaje encontré la
posibilidad de ser yo el que adopte a mi
mamá y mi mamá es la pachamama esa
tierra que nos sustenta y que nos está
pidiendo en algún momento que le
escuchemos porque tiene todavía
historias para contar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]